hãy hai mai tháng người, bộ đông nghiệm MIA US đi a y a y với hợp cùng các cửa liên bàn
công bầu gọi biển sát nhằm cùng cố ăn đing lương thượng và hỗ trợ nghe tị báo trông nước.
Thôi đó, MIA sẽ đẩy nhăng cải cách quy định, gởi bỏ các sâu càng trung trình đôi,
anh đầu tư và năng lực trế biến và quyền ký sự dụng thiệp bảo sản xuất tại điều phương trong hệ thống trường học.
Chính phổ cũng không kết tạm môi trường kinh tế ổn định trường vì trình đôi, bà đạm luôn,
con pro tiền mới giá phố hợp trường vì dân.
Chính phổ chân trải giúp chi giá sản xuất quan yếu thế hệ,
chứ đó tổng thống mấy đường trăm nhìn mạnh mục tiêu cáo sản giá thị báo,
khi giá thăng cao dụng 1 cùng khán hiếm,
tất cảnh thái này được xem là một phần trong trị lực xa hạn,
nhằm bảo vệ cho các cửa ổn lương thượng của xa,
giá phụ thuộc và tăng khán nếu vấn phó, với biển đậm tị trường.